- Before we say goodbye we
like to play a quick roundup!
- Drewth or Dare.
(audience applauding)
- We do anything, we say anything.
And we have Sheralynn
Stratton here. Sheralynn?
- Hi.
- Did I say your name correctly?
- [Sheralynn] Yes, you did.
- Oh, thank God.
- Thank God. And thank
God you wore that pink.
Look how great that is.
- Fuchsia.
- Fuchsia? Oh, fuchsia, oh, I.
Oh!
- [Drew] We have a lipstick that color.
- I love that fuchsia dress.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
All right, what's it gonna be?
Is it gonna be a Drewth or a dare?
- I have a Drewth.
- [Ross] Okay.
- So Drew, have you ever
gone skinny dipping?
And if so, what's your story?
- I mean, which time?
(audience and Ross laughing)
A hotel pool at the-
- What?
- Chateau Marmont in Los Angeles,
for, I don't know, about 15 years.
And a great, like midnight jump
in the lake of Winnipesaukee,
in New Hampshire.
My favorite lake in the world, I think.
And I will say birthday
suit or bathing suit,
if you see a body of water or
rain coming down from the sky,
just get in it.
- Oh, yeah.
(audience applauds)
- You'll never regret it.
You will always dry off pretty quickly.
And you will be immediately
transformed in a nature baptism,
and I just can't recommend it enough.
Recently my girls and I
actually got to go somewhere,
which was such a blessing
and it started pouring rain,
and we were at a beach and we ran outside
and we took a rain
shower and an ocean bath.
And we even brought out
some shampoo and conditioner
and really did, and we like
bathed in the ocean, and then-
- What?
- Yes!
Rain shower, ocean bath.
And it's one of my favorite moments
in the filmstrip of my life.
It made, it was the greatest moment ever.
I did have clothes on, however.
- Okay. Good, good.
- Have you ever skinny dipped Ross?
- Thanks so much for watching everybody.
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
- Where? When?
- My house, my house, my
house. Never in public.
Oh God no, never in, dear God, no.
But yeah, you know, my pool,
my house, gates locked.
(bright theme music)